cam newton's coming back and cam newton
is back and cam newton got it done
yesterday 15 for 19 155 passing yards 15
rushes for 75 yards two touchdowns two
sacks
in a win over the miami dolphins to get
it going here is cam newton talking
about
josh mcdaniels the guy who has designed
this new offense for camp
you know josh has been calling plays the
the same way for a long time so now
knowing you know the dialogue that we
had on the sidelines was unbelievable
just him
being transparent as well as well as
myself being transparent of how we can
attack this defense they they
had a lot of things that you know we
went over and they tried to disguise a
lot but at the end of the day
you know we we made the adjustments and
um
we executed we executed
21 to 11 was the final score it was by
no means a blowout and it's impossible
to tell at this point how good or bad
any team is that's one thing about week
one you never know how good the team is
that beat you and you never know how bad
the team is that you beat
we'll find out as the rest of the season
unfolds but cam newton looked the part i
mean that's what we're always searching
for early in the season who looks the
part who doesn't right cam newton look
like cam newton of old chris
he definitely did mike i i mean first
off i think you know you said 20 21 11
it was i think the score a little bit
you know closer than what it really was
on the field right and kill harry
fumbles on the one foot yard one foot
line going in they missed a chip shot
field goal at one point at no point did
i ever feel like the dolphins were a
threat to win the football game i kept
going man new england should have put
them away already but they didn't but
but regardless
wow i mean wow i mean that's all i can
really say i mean first off cam newton
looked phenomenal running the football
all the things they did around him threw
the ball really well i mean really all
the drop back pass attempts thought he
was on the money with where he put the
ball hanging in the pocket delivering
the right arc and pace on the ball
whatever it may be but you know the big
thing is is kind of what he alluded to
there i mean josh mcdaniels
what he did yesterday
i mean just just that game alone you sat
there and went ooh i mean what are they
going to do here how are they going to
attack you whoa this guy's going this
way this guy's going that way there goes
cam this guy's going that way this guy's
going that way oh it's somebody up the
middle i i just i i really think they're
gonna find the proper formula and cam
newton seems so bought in
and just loving the experience in which
he's involved right now uh it was it was
fun to watch yesterday i had more fun
watching that game and that offense
being unveiled i think than anything in
football yesterday is that weird i just
i really enjoyed it
no no because that was every bit as
stunning to see cam newton in red white
and blue right it was to see tom brady i
still think the most jarring was brady
because we've got 20 years of memory of
him with new england but for cam newton
to be the guy who replaces him and look
they were excited about it the energy
and everything that goes along with it
the one thing chris that concerned me
when i say it looked like the cam newton
of old that's good but it's also bad
because there were too many times he was
hit too many times he was in a cluster
of bodies as they were trying to drag
that giant to the ground
that's the kind of thing that if they
don't manage it properly it's eventually
going to get him injured and i was
confident and hopeful that what we would
see from the patriots yesterday was a
more deliberate attempt to keep him out
of harm's way and when you consider
everything he's been through physically
and and i think they may be seduced the
same way the panthers were sure by this
statue who walks into the facility who
looks indestructible the problem is he's
destructible he's still built of the
same stuff the rest of us are and and i
there were too many times yesterday when
i looked up and we're watching nine
games at once
but too many times i look up and i see
him getting slammed into dragged to the
ground it's like you gotta be a little
more careful with this guy or he's not
gonna be there when december rolls
around yeah they use them there's no
doubt about that and you know i i will
say you're you're right he was in a mosh
pit of bodies a few times you know a few
of them hey it's what he had to do it
was third and shorts fourth and shorts
you know for the most part he does do a
good job of kind of getting down or
trying not to take those type of blows
um but
you know i think new england went into
that game and you know we saw this in
some other games too we could even say
this without josh allen and buffalo
where you i think they're just going in
let's let's get a win in game one let's
get any any advantage we can and the
advantage was
they don't know what to expect from our
cam newton run offense as much as brian
flores knows our offense he doesn't know
this aspect and he hasn't seen any of
that so i think they rode that hard i
think belichick is very smart though
he'll realize like i can't do this to
this guy week after week after week and
then i think what you'll see next week
is the next level you know the stuff off
of that because now okay here we put out
these plays for cam newton and all these
crazy designs all right they're gonna
have a plan formulated for okay we think
this is how a team's gonna defend us
next week and when you start doing that
here comes plan b to screw you over and
they'll have a whole bunch of new plays
off of what we saw them be successful
with this week and i think that's why
they did it mike is probably just to get
the win get off the schneid get off the
hey it's cam newton era we're done with
tom brady and now they can almost use it
as like a decoy as you say like like for
the rest of the year to open up a lot of
other things and of course they'll run
them when they really need them
and not just for the rest of the year
they are going to seattle to play a team
experience defending cam newton right
now there was a time where cam newton
and russell wilson in my mind had the
potential to become the the new tom
brady and peyton manning yeah where they
were crossing paths regularly they met
in the playoffs multiple times one time
the panthers got the better of the
seahawks another time the seahawks got
the better the panthers i think they've
only met twice in the postseason but
this is russell wilson and cam newton
and pete carroll knows how to defend cam
newton yes and maybe maybe this is the
setup maybe yesterday was the setup for
what's coming on sunday when new england
goes to seattle well it could be and you
know again the the this like pete
carroll defense russ i mean jamal adams
that's going to be fun to watch he does
know how to defend this
but
he hasn't defended can't how to defend
cam newton with josh mcdaniels as his
his offensive game planner and i think
that's a different animal because josh
again one yesterday showed
he
like all great offensive coordinators he
exposes the defensive rules or their
adjustments how many times did we see
motions or things like that and you went
whoa they don't have a guy over here for
cam newton you know the one touchdown he
ran out to the right i think was the
first touchdown of the game for cam
newton i mean he nobody two-hand touched
him you know so that's where it's going
to be different you have a a
coaching staff and belichick gets his
nose in the offense too
who will go
hey wait josh if you did this i wouldn't
like this if i was the defensive
coordinator this would be an issue for
me you should do more of that that's
where new england's great they will
figure out how to communicate and use
the stress of cam newton and the things
he can do to a team schematically to
their advantage and they understand how
teams adjust and do that and that's why
they can expose people and you see
people wide open or a run gash you know
a team like they did yesterday every now
and then because they're just on another
level that way we're getting very low on
time in this segment but your thoughts
on the new england defense post free
agency defections and opt out yeah i
still thought it looked really good i
mean again the biggest thing mike and i
know we've talked about it a lot is that
secondary still intact no there's no
patrick chung but if there was a safe a
position on their defense they could
afford to lose it's safety they have
them growing on trees there and that
just no matter who their front seven is
because they can match up with gilmore
and jc jackson and jonathan jones and
then you have mccourty who's a awesome
safety and can match up like a corner
too it allows their front seven to do so
many different things they play off
their secondary which allows them to
hide maybe a lack of talent sometimes on
their front seven because of all the
creative and different things they can
do it's all about that secondary and
it's special and i still think it's
going to be one of the better defenses
in football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports